got something Steven where is this heavy
eye I don't think it's heading quite for
a Corbin victory but I think he will
probably talk I think he'll definitely
top the ballot in the first round labour
have a preferential voting system so you
rank them 1 2 3 I think at that point
Andy Burnham will probably overtake him
in second but I think he's going to have
a much better showing than many people
expected when he got on the ballot and
how is he has he got here I mean what
what's going on in the labour I think
this shows more actually about the
weakness of the other campaigns and it
does of the strength of the Corbin
campaign so you get a sense of if Jeremy
Corbyn became leader Labour Party you
know what you would do and if Liz Kendal
became the Labour Party you know what
she would do but the two frontrunners
the two that are expected to use this as
an opportunity to scrap between
themselves and have a strong sense of
purpose in a mandate have found
something there's really small arguments
about details of policy and so that
they've not managed to enthuse the
electorate and so it really it says that
that they have to up their game and show
more of a sense of purpose and mission
and a reason why Labour Party membership
over them letter in the public I mean it
struck me steam that they've had these
endless internal party hustings and
obviously party members are going to
vote but the only one who's actually
been prepared to go public about what
they believe and go on programs like
this and BBC question time and all this
has been Jeremy Corbyn yeah he has to be
yeah I think and this can kind of
started saying some fairly bold and
radical things and then when it didn't
do so well with members it sort of felt
like she retreated into herself a bit
the other two I think James did exactly
right it's been a war of the bland
they're trying not to offend anyone they
try not to give her a reason not to vote
for them but can anyone think of a
reason to vote for Yvette Cooper or Andy
Burnham I do we know we're party members
do stand on policy I mean they have seen
Ed Miliband fail and a lot of the
candidates are saying look either you
think basically the vote has got it
wrong and they need a dose of moving to
the left or we need to move to the
centre what do we know what well our
team is boaters one of the challenges
with this kind of poll is it's just very
hard to know what the party members
actually think what they really look
like that very hard to poll because it's
such a tiny group of the population
these days and you don't know what their
real composition is you can't tell if
the polls accurate
what you do know is that they want they
want something to vote for and so
they're very open to the idea of Labor
changing position if it needs to to win
but they need to have something to
infuse them and at the moment you've got
Corbin who is enthusiam them you've got
a kendall campaign that's got a lot of
the right positions but part of it seems
almost disdainful of the Labor Party
membership and then you've got the two
in the middle just aren't giving them
enough to make them think yep I can go
out I can vote for them I can compromise
on this that or the other because I
believe that will help labour win and
they'll be better for the country and
unless they're enthused they're gonna
drift off and at the moment it's
drifting to the left do we even know who
the electorate are I mean it's the first
time we've had an election under these
rules with one member one vote for
labour choosing candidates we've also
had these people who can sign up
personally do we know who signed up
what's going on we don't quite know
exactly who signed up we know then there
are some trade union affiliates we know
there are registered supporters it
looked their peers from the poll we've
seen today then registered supporters
are voting slightly heavier for Jeremy
Corbyn but we won't know the exact
composition of the electorate until that
vote on the 12th of September which
would suggest that this isn't a very
clever process Labour's good well I mean
the idea was this was a completion of a
kind of Blair reform one member one vote
member the previous election you could
be an MP you could have 10 votes as a
union member as a member of a society so
the idea was this would simplify it and
make perfect sense but it's not really
the system's full I mean the electorate
the system is the system the candidates
aren't playing within that in a way that
maximizes their chance of winning and
the thing that they're not doing is
being clear enough about how they would
change the Labour Party so that it can
win in the future and that failure is a
really is a failure in the candidate and
the way they're behaving or not the
candidates are in the campaign it's not
full of the system seem we're talking
about the Labour leadership contest
there is of course a contest for deputy
leader and a contest for candidate for
London mayor who potentially could be
the only person in the Labour Party
exercising some power outside in local
government do we know how those contests
are going for deputy leader or for
london mayor and the deputy leader looks
like being a fairly foregone conclusion
for tom
now at least according to the patterns
of the local nominations according to
the polling we've seen and my feeling
based on the hustings is that he's doing
quite well and he'll probably get enough
to edge over the line again like Jeremy
Corbyn he's a Marmite character so he's
not going as many second preferences as
his rivals the mayoral contest that it's
kind of a three free-for-all tessa giles
very popular among members Sadiq Khan
has the ability to reach out into the
wider country and recruit people both
from sort of various religious
communities and from the trade unions if
he can get enough new recruits he can be
an Eaton - Tess's lead but it's still
test chels to lose